et je reçois présents eric boutié
bonsoir vous avez photographe
indépendant ans résidant à ça la ferme
du mousseau c'est à elancourt et une
résidence qui marque un retour aux
sources pour vous annoncer avec une
grande eu dans cette grandi dans cette
ville dans le quartier de la ville dieu
pendant sept ans où il est ensuite allez
vous installer ailleurs avec votre
famille et 31 ans après votre naissance
vous revenez ici
comment est venue l'idée de cette
résidence c'est vous qui avez souhaité
re découvrir ce territoire
non en fait c'est vraiment un pur hasard
et c'est un projet qui est plein de
plein de coïncidence en fait c'est la
responsable de la ferme du mousseau
khiêm a rencontré un jour qui m'a
proposé ce projet de résidence en voyant
mon travail et on a découvert enfin
voilà plutôt quand elle m'a dit je
travaille à la ferme du mousseau et long
cours je lui ai dit voilà c'est très
étrange parce que c'est la ville où j'ai
passé les huit premières années de ma
vie j étais jamais retourner jusqu'à
jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais ce qui est
marrant c'est que votre travail en tant
que photographe a surtout consisté à
travailler sur les questions de
l'enfance où le territoire c'est bien ça
mais vous étiez donc jamais revenu ici
j'ai dit non non je n'étais jamais
retourné sur ce lieu pourtant je vois là
sur la nationale 10 jeux jeux allaient
j'allais très souvent voilà je passais
devant ces tours en tournant la tête
dans tous les sens pour les voir mais
j'avais jamais fait cette démarche de
retourner sur les lieux s'est enfoncé la
rue bersot à l'exposition qui est
présenté actuellement à la ferme du
mousseau donc du côté d'elancourt le but
pour vous c'était quoi justement c'était
d'aller sur place de vous laisser guider
par des sensations des sentiments vous
redécouvrez un petit peu le lieu et vous
prenez des clichés comme parce que même
en fait j'ai reculé au maximum 7 cette
première fois la première fois où je
suis retourné là-bas parce que je savais
que ce serait un
un moment assez fort et voilà vu que je
travaille beaucoup
très peu sur le concept mais beaucoup
dans l'émotion dans la photographie
voilà dans l'émotion j'ai contraire
reculé au maximum ce temps là et c'était
voilà très très fort quand j'y suis
retourné j'ai beaucoup photographié la
première fois où je suis retourné il
encourt pour mme pour sur les voilà à la
vie dieu dans ce quartier de mon enfant
sentiment quand lorsque vous êtes venu
vous avez redécouvert c'était quoi rien
n'avait changé ou au contraire tout
avait si c'est très troublant parce que
voilà je me suis senti un peu comme
gulliver fins et c'est vraiment une
dimension à la fois très familière et à
la fois des choses qui changent sans
qu'on sache exactement quoi l'école me
semblait très loin de chez moi alors
qu'en fait c'était une minute à pied
voilà tout me semblait complètement
disproportionnée parce que lors la
présentation de l'exposition vous parlez
d'un dysfonctionnement temporel voilà
exactement c'est s'interdire présence là
bas c'est un dysfonctionnement
temporaire
voilà à la fin on est dans un endroit
qu'on connaît pas c'est à dire ça fait
ça faisait donc à peu près 20 ans je
n'avais pas été dans cet endroit donc
voilà j'ai pleuré en avoir avec elle on
court aujourd'hui est à la fois on y est
en jeu reconnaissait tout il y avait des
espèces d'automatismes qui se mettait en
marche c'est pour ça oui que je parle de
dysfonctionnements du temporel c'est à
dire que c'est un peu comme si voilà ma
place n'était pas vraiment j'avais pas
vraiment être là je suis plus habitant
aujourd'hui d'elancourt je viens ici
pour photographier les traces de mon
enfance donc des choses qui sont
définitivement passé et à quelque chose
d'un peu de oued de perturber alors vous
avez photographié quoi alors j'ai
photographié au début je me suis surtout
concentré en fait nous a effectivement
plutôt sur des natures mortes ou sur des
paysages donc j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
accès à l'école primaire dans laquelle
j'étais ces quartiers d'elancourt
absolument de lavilledieu je suis monté
sur le toit de l'école acte de rhodes
d'adultes suprême et puis au fur et à
mesure comme je commençais à prendre
voilà beaucoup de beaucoup de
photographies traces de sol j'ai
photographié beaucoup les racines
d'arbres dans la cour de récréation ce
genre de choses je me suis dit qu'il
fallait un peu humaniser cette cette
série de photographies
j'ai donc décidé voilà de photographier
j'ai retrouvé une amie d'enfance par
exemple qui a fait sa scolarité avec moi
et l'autre coïncidence c'est que je suis
devenu papa aussi en préparant cette
exposition ce qui n'était pas du tout
prévu non plus à la base est ce qui fait
que voilà je me suis aussi retrouvé dans
une autre position c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai un fils en plus qui
à l'âge que j'avais quand j'étais à la
vie de dieu donc voilà j'ai aussi
directement été dans une danse vers un
chemin très intime
en photographiant nous l'avons mis en
scène et dernier exactement exactement
c'est à dire qu'à la fois il ya des
photographies qui sont des sortes de
constats d'aujourd'hui voilà comment
c'est la vie dieu avec un regard posé
sur le passé et il ya aussi quelques
photographies de deux gens proches de
gens qui témoignent de de cette histoire
comme cet ami d'enfance que j'ai là par
contre plus mis en scène c'est à dire
que voilà c'était pas juste de la
capture d'instantanés mais c'était
provoquer gens c'est un travail très
mélancolique comment on pourrait définir
c'est un travail qui parlent du passé
oui donc c'est plutôt c'est plutôt
nostalgique ouais grave et beaucoup de
nostalgie ça a été une expérience
difficile de revenir ou au contraire non
non c'était plutôt très enrichissant de
fer se voit là je souhaite à tout le
monde d'avoir la possibilité de comme ça
de faire le d'avoir la possibilité de
retourner sur le sur le terrain de son
enfance non c'est plutôt plutôt positif
après voilà la photographie pour moi
très très faim pas que pour moi pour la
plupart des gens entre l ue lien au
souvenir au temps qui passe donc c'est
aussi un acte comme ça de fixer un temps
qui est révolu c'est aussi un acte que
je trouve assez nostalgique à la bonne
vous avez travaillé avec les enfants de
cette école il devient aussi encore
actuellement vous y étiez cet après midi
par une solution et cet après midi je
donnais des comme ça des petites
interventions à l'école de la villedieu
voilà vous sortent des changes un peu
comme ils m'ont accueilli j'avais envie
aussi leur donne ça va être surprenant
de venir dans la peau du professeur
cascadeur soutenu absolument en plus
j'ai eu une belle surprise aujourd'hui
c'est que ma professeure de cp est venue
alors que je ne savais pas me rendre
visite parce qu'elle savait que j'étais
là et voilà c'était un gros morceau de
passer qui revenu qui revenue en face
voilà et de façon parallèle j'ai
travaillé donc avec l'école d'arts
plastiques de la ferme du mousseau pour
faire des voix des stages avec les
élèves y aura aussi une sorte de work
shop qui serait avec des adouls laissons
à la fin du mois donc ce sera 27 et 28
ans d'ailleurs pour ce travail sur ces
stages vous pouvez vous renseigner bien
sûr auprès de la municipalité des
encours ou de la ferme du mousseau
directement l' enseignement qui
s'affiche l'exposition est à découvrir à
la ferme du mousseau jusqu'au 31 octobre
il ya une autre partie de votre travail
aussi qui est présenté sur la ville
d'elancourt c'est à l'hôtel de ville
un travail que vous avez menées entre
2005 et 2011 à travers le monde entier
des pays demandant dépaysement deux mots
avec cela c'est un travail un peu un peu
différent mais toujours empreinte cette
même mélancolie nostalgie du temps qui
passe c'est light motiv un petit peu de
votre travail oui on peut on peut dire
ça en fait le principe de dépaysement
c'est que j'ai utilisé un appareil voilà
cette idée je sais pas s'il ya des
photographies qui vont passer ou pas
mais ça on va voir quelle grave un peu
particulière de vue réalisées ce matin à
l'hôtel de ville voilà j'ai utilisé en
fait un appareil qui a quatre objectifs
et qui fut en fait des photographies sur
un temps de deux secondes
donc c'est vraiment un travail sur le
mouvement c'est le début du cinéma en
fait et je les compte en fait j'ai fait
ce travail en rapport avec d'autres
travaux antérieurs qui avaient beaucoup
lieu beaucoup lien pardon à mon enfance
donc là c'était un petit peu voilà une
fois que j'ai cercle et le territoire de
l'enfance qu'est ce qui se trouve un peu
à l'extérieur et l'appareil photo seul
appareil lomographic c'est bien simple
ils allèrent en juillet ça c'est plutôt
un jouet enfin super g j'utilise
beaucoup les appareils jouer oui j'adore
le reste dans à peine de l'enfance en
exactement ce qu'on appelle les
appareils au celsa paris sont pas
professionnels qui sont des appareils
amateurs j'adore parce qu'ils sont très
maniable d'utilisation il permet d'être
beaucoup dans la spontanéité et puis on
n'est pas crédible quand on fait des
photos avec sa j'adore
et justement ça change le rapport à la
photo a beaucoup changé au fur et à
mesure du temps maintenant sol on fait
des photos lorsque vous allez présenter
ce travail aux enfants par exemple comme
cet après midi ils vous disent quoi
qu'ils font déjà des photos tous les
jours avec les téléphones peut-être
parents primaire 6,6 alors là on n'est
jamais un je vous confirme avec des
téléphones avec leur console de jeu ou
si ce que je savais pas mais les
consoles de jeux pour aussi des photos
apparaissent al qaïda non en partie - je
leur montre une pellicule
voilà la magie opère et
j'essaye de leur expliquer voilà comment
c'était y'a pas si longtemps et comment
on faisait défaut la photographe c'est
un vrai métier pour eux ça alors ça leur
dit quelque chose
ah oui il photographe animalier sai
connais je sais pas pourquoi mais dans
ce qui leur plaît beaucoup
vos projets pour la suite justement de
projet pour la face presque se tourne en
fait absolument les projets pour la
suite y en a plusieurs une exposition
collective avec un collectif qui
s'appelle photo povera paris au mois de
novembre qui est justement un collectif
de photographes qui travaille beaucoup
autour d'eux des caméras jouets des
appareils jouer qui prône un peu une
photographie comme ça sans cibler non
conceptuel et puis 2013
la suite est donc vous êtes heureux
d'être revenu sur ce territoire vous
allez peut-être venir vous y installer
n'ont pas forcément dans je pense pas
mais c'est une très belle expérience sur
un avis merci avec moutier d'être venu
nous parler donc de ce travail à
découvrir à l'hôtel de ville
et puis et principalement la ferme du
mousseau pour travail mené sur la ville
d'elancourt sur ce quartier de la ville
dieu et long cours la ville lieu +31
absolument terre'blanche et le nom de
l'exposition jusqu'au 31 octobre pour
terminer ce set 8 le rappel des titres
de ce 8 octobre les sujets que nous
avons abordé ce soir la ville de la
verrière n'a pas connu de construction
depuis 40 ans mais celles qui vont venir
sont importantes c'est le maire qui
l'annoncent nous sommes revenus sur les
détails au cours de cette édition ce
week-end c'était l'opération micro dons
pour soutenir les projets de solidarité
internationale
nous étions devant un supermarché de
voisins-le-bretonneux avec l'association
but tiers-monde
il s'appelle françois et théo il son
père et fils mordu tous les deux de bmx
une pratique leurs activités ensemble
sur le terrain de voisins-le-bretonneux
vous les avez découverts ce soir et puis
le portrait de thomas andré champion du
monde u23 de duathlon le licencié du
triathlon club de saint quentin a
remporté son titre il ya tout juste une
semaine des sujets à retrouver également
dans l'actuelle toute image de la
rédaction à 20h30 ce lundi soir et puis
dès à présent sur notre site internet
rendez vous demain mardi 18 heures
toujours en direct pour un nouveau 7 8
avec notamment un débat consacré au
mariage homosexuel faut-il autoriser
faut-il avoir recours à un référendum d
élue des yvelines se prononceront sur ce
plateau vous pouvez déjà laissez vos
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux sur
les différentes pages de l'émission je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée
rendez vous demain 18h en direct sur
télé fils
calmons nous taire